- Happiness is a byproduct,
not an actual destination.
And so people have this
misconception that they're gonna
find happiness like it's Europe
and they're never
gonna move out. (laughs)
Happiness is a
byproduct of certain behaviors
and can set yourself up to win
and you can set
yourself up to be happy.
The sad thing is happiness is a
learned skill and a lot of our
houses don't teach happiness.
That was the situation
I was in and so I actually just
started studying
people that were happy
and I saw what
the algorithm was.
What did they do that's similar
and for me I don't focus on
happiness as much as harmony.
I don't really believe in the
word balance 'cause balance is a
binary thing like oof,
it's a great very tedious.
Harmony is saying my
life has many components.
I'm a woman,
I'm a mom,
I am sexual,
I am spiritual.
I'm a businessperson, all of
those limbs have to have tone
and that brings about harmony.
That brings about satisfaction.
If only have one limb
that is very buff and
the rest of us is atrophied,
we have disharmony,
we have dissatisfaction but
there's no human school and
so that's what I'm
looking at starting.
I want to be able to teach
people emotional and mindfulness
skills so that they can
gain tone in every area.
- From my standpoint, you know
since Jewel took it up here,
I will take into one very narrow
place that I've been really
trying to spend a lot of time
on and that's perspective.
It's so interesting to me why
I deem myself happy because
I just am so grateful.
- Mhmmm.
- Like the thing we got excited
about of you know the data
behind being a human
being is 400 trillion to 1.
When you just start there and
you realize forget about the
odds of like beating
homelessness and like other or
like being born in a communist
country like just actually
becoming a human.
I always make the joke that your
mom could have had
another glass of wine.
Or your dad could have
been late because of traffic.
The odds are so insane.
I'm just so grateful for what
I have versus what I don't have
and I think people just have all
these admirations and envy and
all these hard-wiring things.
To me, it's perspective
just like there's always,
I just generally believe there's
always somebody that has it
worse and the problem is that's
where I default into mentally
and have practiced
to put myself there
versus somebody's got it better.
(light music)